Mình hả dinh quá nguồn màng
Cô sống lôi kỳ thử thách ta
Cô không đừng đặc, có không đồng ý đôi trả
Búng cuộc gả ta hả cho tôi nhạc
Sáng mai có cuộc họ có cơm kia chưởng thật lắm
Tất cả bướng như trên
Tà phải bướng lơt bằng tử lực
Tinh cử đầy hướng
Tà là trên
Tà mạnh mẽ
Tà kinh cử
Mật cũng tố được
Bồ cũng gắng được
Như là trên
Phải chưởng được
Không dì có thể vẻ gảy được tà
Dỏ có lớn đuy càng được
Không dì là không thể thích ứng
Dương lơt để chở nên chứng chắn hơn
Như là trên
Tà lụng hoại hướng
Tà không được ui đâu
Điều đó không sai
Có nữa
Mẹ
Nhưng chè dụ lần đến đâu
Cũng thần làm mát
Vạm mạnh
Thì lụng có dừng thơm chè hướng chắc
Để dừa vào
Mặc bệm biểu nhanh
Mặc được phép bệm
Được phép nhỏ
Và được phép dừa vào dừng thơm chắc chắn hơn
Và châu đôi mất của chá mẹ
Tà vẫn lúc chảy là những thấm mạnh nhỏ
Có một lời
Tà chó từ vận nâng
Ở đó
Tà vẫn được là những đứa chảy
Được là những lúc mâm
Chưa tưởng bí đồ xa
Vận nhỏ mẽ như vậy
Dù tà có lớn
Vận là có nhỏ cho mắt chá mẹ
Tất chính là khi
Những dẫn chè chở về bất nhau
Để đang lắt lại tất cả những yêu thương
Tất cả những yêu thương
Được là có một đứa